i have a friend
uh who used to work work with me and
i caught up with him and his story
he basically went from like uh
average like an average job like you
wouldn't look at this person say oh
that's a star career and um they're good
they're doing well obviously but they
were doing like normal person well
and they went from normal person well to
making like
to personally making like 15 million
dollars in the last year just by
the they basically quit their job and
they went down a crypto rabbit hole and
started betting on things in defy and
they started playing with all the d5
projects investing their money in d5
and they didn't have a huge base of
capital they have you know
call it half a million dollars that they
put in
and to turn a half a million dollars if
and if you have no path in your career
to being like
a
you know a deca millionaire right like
if you don't have a path or you're like
yeah i'm gonna have you money to go
from no path no no like reasonable
storyline that makes sense there you
have a job at a company that pays you
good salary and that's that
to that is amazing to me and awesome and
like you know just like blew my mind
more so than these guys who become
multi-billionaires who were like
prodigies and like invented the protocol
or invested 250k in a random token it's
like this is somebody who just took
their own money out of the stock market
and was like instead of investing in
apple google and facebook i'm going to
investigate crypto and turned a normal
amount a normal like life savings amount
of money into a life-changing amount of
money and i want to have him on to tell
his full story because it actually has
like a bunch of twists and turns um that
are like kind of amazing so i'm gonna
ask him if he'll come on and share it do
i know they're willing to
uh yeah you know them um i don't know if
they're willing to share but if they are
it's gonna make for an amazing episode
uh i'll ask them if you'll do it next
week did they um
did they earn the did they uh sell do
they have usd or like some type of
stable
currency
um no
they're they're still in crypto like 100
or 100 plus percent because they you
know but but is it stable like a bit
like a a popular thing
uh it's a mix of popular things and like
something they could sell at least
everything's liquid if they wanted to
cash out and say i'm done i'm going to
malibu and i'm going to chill i'm going
to pretend that this year never existed
and i basically won a lottery they could
do that because we have a buddy in our
chat group who said he made all this
money in some crazy coin but he's like i
can't sell it so it's like that's
different that's like uh those are like
either illiquid like oh there's this
coin but it's not listed yet or it's
liquid but there's like no trading
volume whatsoever on this coin and so
like yeah if you have 10 million dollars
and you go to even 100 000 it'll crash
the price of the coin that's not what
this is that's that's a different thing
um
that's a what that is is
i i make a million coins i keep 999 000
for myself
and then i sell one of them for a dollar
and oh now the total value of my thing
is a million dollars and it's like no
it's not really you there's such a lit
such a small amount of the supply out
there being sold it's not indicative of
the true price this is what i'm talking
about is not that situation is there any
other person all right so you have a
story of someone who did 500 000 to 15
million
i just told you about this guy who in
like two years
this person
non-technical
never was a trader or financial person
like they would own like a index fund or
mutual fund before that didn't know how
to spell blockchain um you know like
this person is that's why this blows my
mind it's not just this like i know that
amount is not the craziest amount of
money it's an awesome amount of money
for anybody but
what's crazy is
point a to point b it makes no sense
it's like how could those two points
connect in that amount of time it's
mind-blowing to me so i told you a story
about this dude chris who did 250 000 up
to a billion you just said 500 000 to 15
million do we know anyone else that has
this like crazy crazy journey
uh personally you've talked about this
guy you talked about somebody right that
you're yeah and a friend that that they
made
1 million to 100 million
yeah so at its peak when bitcoin was uh
60 000. so i don't know whatever is that
discount it okay i have another one uh
there is a kid who i call him a kid
because he was actually a kid he i built
this a product called blab back in the
days like kind of like clubhousey you
could basically go hang out chat with
people and this kid used to come home
every day from school he used to get on
and chat and he didn't chat in the other
rooms that had 13 year olds he came to
our rooms because he loved technology
startups he wanted to be in the startup
scene
and
i think he was maybe 13 at the time
okay so fast forward it's been like six
years since then so now he's like let's
say 21 or something like that
it's been it's been a while
and um
he created some but he was he's a
technical guy he created a protocol like
i was like oh what you been up to like
how's your startup going and he's like
uh it's yeah startups okay we haven't
been focusing on it for last few months
i was like i know man it's tough you got
just hanging in there buddy you know
just pivot
he's like actually like we ended up
creating this thing anonymously on one
of these random like side chains and it
was like blah blah some bunch of terms i
don't even understand
you know it's a it's a derivatives
perpetual contract for you know adding
liquidity to this blah blah i'm like
okay i don't understand what you're
saying
uh he's like yeah the market cap of it
like you know basically like the market
cap of it is like 900 million right now
and you know i think he cashed out 10
million dollars in this he's like he's
like dude it's been insane the market
cap went up like crazy now it's at 200
million
and he's like i was able to like take
out like a life-changing amount of money
he i took out 10 million he was he was
like he was asking me because he goes
i heard you guys talking about charities
and charity water you told the charity
water stores really moved like i've set
aside seven figures to donate
you're like what i was like you've set
aside seven figures like like are you
seven years old how did this happen
where what if what has happened to this
amount of time like i used to talk to
you when you would come home from eighth
grade and get online like you're
donating millions of dollars to charity
now like what is again
a and b it broke my brain and i don't
mean this as an insult to them like if
they're if they were only 15 then so
they're still only like 19.
yeah i think they're 20 now or 21
something like that it's been like seven
years since we've made that thing so um
you know it's not it's not mind-blowing
to me that this person is successful in
both cases i
i really like this person that's why i
used to hang out with them that's why i
used to work with one of them i think
they're really smart and we're going to
be normal person successful
it's like when you know i went like my
sister went to high school with this
girl lily galici who's like this super
famous instagram star now she's like has
her own tv show on bravo
and it's like wait that's the lilly girl
who used to come to our house after
school like she was just like a normal
girl like wait that's her like that
doesn't even look like her anymore like
yeah she's had some work done right
it's like just mind-blowing to know a
normal person who's like yeah that's a
cool normal
they'll do well in life to be like no
actually they're like
one of those crazy outlier stories and
in a way that you wouldn't have
otherwise predicted you know it didn't
make any sense like
you know it's not it's not that that was
their skill set and they tried try tried
that thing for 10 years and finally hit
it's like just i don't know where they
just did this thing and it hit and
crypto is this amazing thing like that
so by the way um i'm going to say
something
when i first talked to my friend i
caught up with my friend
i felt insanely jealous i was like so j
i was happy for him and i like him and
all that but i was also like
i was like in my head i was just like
what the have i been doing with my
life
with the the friend that used to work
for you both of them both the same
reaction yeah because it feels weird
because you're like oh wait you kind of
looked up to me yeah
now i'm like you know way less
successful than you uh so like what just
happened you just like catapulted really
crazy like yeah between the last time we
caught up and now
there is jealousy there it's easy
and i just want to say like you know
an interesting thing to observe is what
is your reaction to hearing stories like
this um there's a part of me that i'm
not proud of which gets jealous of it
but that used to be like
it used to be i would feel that i
wouldn't really acknowledge that that's
what i was feeling and i would kind of
find reasons why it was like ah that's
just luck or
um like
you know well they probably are taking a
bunch of risk and they might lose it all
and i'm kind of secretly rooting for it
to not not all work out just so
perfectly as it has
that's gone but i still got a little bit
of that like jealousy paying left and
i'd say the interesting thing is
my coach said this to me he goes
uh you know you'll encounter people in
your life where your success just
reminds them of their failure
and they're not focused on your success
they're focused on their fail your
success has reminded them of their
failure or your abundance has reminded
them of their lack
and uh if you notice that in yourself
you want to
be aware of that and change that and if
you find other people and you're like oh
these people are haters like uh you know
just understand what's coming out they
don't actually hate you it's
uh your success has reminded them of
some failing that they have in
themselves and that's where their
attention is gone and so uh yeah i
wanted to share that because i
definitely felt this like crazy feeling
that i hadn't felt in a long time but
these stories were so mind-blowing that
i could i was like wow
this i don't even know what to say
i feel lucky to
know who i know
which we have the same group basically
that i've like
these stories that sound unbelievably
true
i'm a big yeah i know that person um
i saw it it was wild so like an example
is
mois ali selling native deodorant for
100 million dollars two years after
starting it i was in he we shared an
office when he was starting it and i saw
him try to learn facebook ads like i saw
the thing come to fruition i saw it
right in front of my eyes every single
day for like six or ten months
um and that was almost half the journey
[Music]
you